All right, welcome to today's Zoom call. It is the 6th of April. My oldest daughter is birthday, so
so very happy day for me ready years ago. So let's get into some details. Remember to everybody that
first thing you should do if you have a question is to search for it because on our blog and on our
website we have lots of answered questions and pretty soon on our membership site hopefully next week
there's going to be more questions answered and actually on the membership site what I did is I put
a little question box that you could actually post your questions in there and I think wow,
that's a really good question. I might even just make a video on that question so you might make
videos out of the questions, especially if you think there's good questions for the video and
that's where you'll post your questions for the Zoom call. So instead of emailing the questions in
two cutters clinic at Gmail or two year liaison or two import cutters clinic just so they don't get
missed you could just put your questions in that box. So it's really nice little form. You can
fill out, you just log in to the membership site and you'll put the questions in that box.
In the meantime and even after that I always go to this little new dad magnifying glass on our website and
you could ask a question and you'll get a whole bunch of different pages where that question might
already be answered so that you don't have to wait for the Zoom call. Of course I love answering
questions on the Zoom call so but if you want to get to a question and answer faster that's a good thing.
My new book again is the seven phases of detoxification that's available as a free download.
That's that you need anything else to read but this may help some of your family members or friends
that maybe don't have cancer and it just talks about the why we my philosophy of detoxification
isn't just supporting your liver you have to support all the phases of detoxification. So that is a
term that I made up so there isn't anything else that you'll ever read about seven phases of
detox. You're only going to read about phase one phase two and maybe you'll read about phase three
detoxification that has to do with liver physiology. I point the rest of those terms but I think it's
really fitting that it helps convince them to understand detoxification so you can download it's not very
long book and it's a free download of the site. All right let's get to questions. My brother Bob
had his genetic review Zoom call and was and we asked Ann about red light sauna therapy. Could you
speak about red light sauna therapy. So sauna is obviously something that we're very big because the
idea of using a sauna is that you are taking pressure off of your liver. So if you go to sauna
the benefits of the sauna is that you're sweating in the sauna so you're using your skin as a major
organ of detoxification which it is. So by sweating you are helping getting rid of toxins and
poisons in your body and that can be extremely beneficial. So a sauna to increase your body temperature
just to a sweat is huge because it takes pressure off your liver. A sauna can also sometimes not always
depends on the sauna depends on the person can also raise core body temperature. Now there's
different studies that people do in saunas with different saunas and such can it raise but core
body temperature and the studies say yes but the truth is that every person is different and it may not
raise your core body temperature. So you can't make those promises with a sauna that's raising
core body temperature but it's still good for you to use a sauna if you're in there sweating. Now there's
other additions that many saunas come with different light therapy that can have benefits. So what's
the benefit of like red light therapy? So first of all red light therapy that there's many different
definitions of that. So there is laser therapy so there's the use of lasers for helping healing
but when we're talking about them putting different colored filters over lights and having that
be a therapy, it's more so dealing with a person's psychology maybe. I don't know really the physiological
benefits. I don't know how much that's been proven with different lights. I think it does. I know it has
a change in your frontal cortex because different lights, different colors can affect your frontal
cortex. And if you go on our blog again and you read or you do a search for parasympathetic, sympathetic
tone what are the ways that you would calm a person's sympathetic from a functional neurology perspective
is to use colored glasses. Like even using sunglasses, what's even better is like rose colored
sunglasses, mawvy colored sunglasses, have been proven to decrease sympathetic tone. So red light
therapy, there can be some benefits to just slowing your sympathetic. So your sympathetic nervous system
remembers your fight or flight mechanism, it is housed in the part of the brain called the
messence cephalon. So different colors, red rose colored mob can slow the messence cephalon down
and that can be hugely beneficial for anybody dealing with immune issues and immune countervise
and cancer, you try to stimulate parasympathetics. So any way that you could decrease sympathetic tone
can be beneficial to then increase parasympathetic tone. So that's where that would be beneficial,
but it would be great. The same person had histamine genes, so and recommended that he
don't eat lechdovers, but freeze individual meal size healthy to thaw them in their refrigerator
overnight. Could you please speak about this? So whatever we talk about histamine, it's not about
eliminating histamines because that is literally impossible. So all foods contain some histamines,
and the purpose really isn't even to eliminate all histamines if you if you could, that isn't even
necessary. So understand histamines are in a lot of different foods and a lot of foods have
higher sources of histamines than others. Foods that even have moderate or even low amounts of
histamines, the older the food is, the more histamines it will have in its contents. So that's the idea
that eat as many lechdover foods. But histamines are also made in your body. Your immune
risk part of your immune response is a histamine response. We make all these different cytokines,
chemokines, and histamines are in that classification, and they are an immune precursor and an immune
stimulant to deal with something in your body. That's why when you're exposed to pollen, you get a
histamine reaction. Now that histamine is made by your mass cells in your body, and then it's
cleared through a different gene called your H-N-M-T gene that makes a DAO histamine enzyme that
breaks down histamine in the tissues and gets rid of it. But the idea of decreasing histamines in your
diet, especially if you have a lot of genes, the DAO genes, not the H-N-M-T genes, you don't make,
if you have defects in your DAO genes, you don't make a lot of the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine
in the gut. So by decreasing the amount of histamines you eat, it will decrease the amount of
histamine reaction in your gut that would require an excess production of DAO enzyme, and if you
have defects on those pathways, you don't make enough already. And so it can decrease the inflammation,
overall inflammation of your gut. Again, it is not a perfect science because you can't get rid of
all histamines. You're just trying to reduce the load. So if you think of histamines as a bucket,
when you fill up the bucket too much it overflows and you could have a hyperhistamine reaction,
you just try to reduce the load. Here's an article from our blog,
the low histamine diet, high histamine food list. I have multiple articles about histamine
in our blog because histamines are a major issue, especially with the COVID and the COVID vaccine,
having mass cell issues could kill people. So histamines are a player in that. They're not the only
player in mass cell activation issues, but they are a player in that. So anything you could do to
reduce histamines the better often it is. Other articles that talk about histamine and different
cancers too. So go to this little thing here again and search for histamines and you'll come up with this
article on histamines. Next question. We've read a lot and watched your blog videos about blocking
EMFs. I thought EMF radiates in all directions. So if so, how does the hedron block EMFs? Good question.
So the hedron is this little device that you stick on the back of your phone like this,
and it can help with EMFs. Did you notice what I just said? It can help with EMFs. There is nothing
that is going to block EMFs altogether except putting your phone in a Faraday cage. So a Faraday cage
is just anything that completely blocks all electromagnetic function. So we have those little
sleeves that you can buy. I think there are 20 bucks on our web store. There are little soft
material sleeves and you can stick your phone in and you can fold it over and it will grow it up
and you literally will block all EMFs coming through your phone. But you will also block all usage
of your phone because the phone won't receive any data from it because it's completely blocked.
So what are you going to do? You can't use your phone then. So but it's a good thing to put your
phone in that little Faraday sleeve because it will then block all EMFs. I mean, when you're at night
or when you're not using your phone or when you don't need to use your phone, some people put them
in their pockets and when they put their phone in the pocket, they just slip it right into the sleeve.
So they're not going to be able to receive any phone calls. They won't receive any text until you
take it off of that and then it connects with the network again and it goes ping, ping, ping, ping, ping,
ping. Now you can always text or emails or phone missed calls. But that's the only way to give
you full protection. The heat run gives you some protection. I opinion better than the heat run
is the safe sleeve. So safe sleeve is the brand name of a phone case. I just got a new phone
a couple of weeks ago and I'm waiting for them to come out with the size safe sleeve. We had
ordered some I have to check with Dustin to see if we got them in for the S21 or S22 and I think it's
the S22, the Galaxy S22 to do. So that is the best thing short of using a Faraday case. So you can
still receive phone calls and stuff but literally when you have it in the safe sleeve which is just a
phone case but it looks kind of, it looks kind of early 2000s because it's just kind of the older
style. You have to have it that way if you're going to have protection. So that's even much better
than the heat run. So I will have a heat run and a safe sleeve. So it's just for the money it gives you
the best protection or something like that. And understand with anything with EMFC that thing is
going to protect you fully. You're going to have an EMFC exposure and you just got to try to reduce
that exposure as best you possibly care. Do you have anything on blood type diets? Is there anything
to that theory? These are two different questions. So the blood type diets was a book that was put out by
Dr. Amaro. I think was to say years ago, probably back in the 80s. And he used blood types to say that
the way we evolved was based upon the blood type we evolved from different, I don't know, whatever
that that's why a type O could eat meat to the type A doesn't eat meat or whatever it is in a type B
should it be a vegan or whatever I don't remember. I read the book a long time ago when it came out.
Well, I have major issues with it because I don't believe we evolved number one. So it doesn't make any
sense to me whatsoever in that way. Do I think though that some people do better on a vegan diet and
some people do better on a you know they have to eat meat three times a day in order to keep their
their blood B12 and their red blood cell content high enough at oxygen oxygen of red
their red blood cells up. Yes, I do, but I don't think it has anything to do with what type blood you
have. So if it's like, oh, no, man, I'm a type A and it says I should be eating meat and boy,
I have to eat meat. I think that's just a coincidence. I don't think it has to do with what type
that's just my opinion. But I do know that there are people that do much better on different
diets and there's certainly food sensitivities that you have to stay away from what you need to deal
with that. So I always suggest you do a Cyrix test if you really want to know about food sensitivities
and if you have food antibodies, that's what makes the most sense from a scientific perspective
in my book is that do you have circulated antibodies to that food or that peptide of that food that
then every time you eat that food, you end up having an inflammatory reaction and it possibly
constantly want to be an issue. That's how you should test for it, not based on blood type.
Next part of that question is also what preparation do you recommend if I decide to follow through
with mastectomy? We'll make sure you contact your liaison. There are some things that we want to do with
it is individualized based upon the supplements that you're currently taking. So make sure you
contact your liaison. If you want to make a point with me, do that too. Some of these questions are
said to people's liaison. So I said, Ashley, does Dr. Cutters know about royal vibe ultrasound? Yes,
I do. We heard it's better than the right for sheet. The lady said that she used the right for sheet
and her tumor grow. She said it didn't go deep enough. Well, I would 100% agree with that lady
if she was using most of the right for sheets that are on the market. So most of them, remember,
maybe you don't remember, but a lot of interviews people have asked me about the right for sheet and
how I qualify the quality of a right for sheet. And the quality of a right for sheet is based on
number one. If it doesn't have enough power to go through the person's body, it's completely worth us.
But that is literally paid out of 10 right for sheets that are on there. There's one right for
sheet made in Canada where the guy is telling people that the right for sheet goes out 30 feet. If
you tested it because a friend that had one and tested it, it goes out six inches. So these
some of these companies will just outright lie to you. It's very disturbing. So to me, the most,
the best machines on the market are the true right for the GB 4000. As far as the power of
putting the machine, if you don't have enough power to get through a person's body, then it's not
going to do anything. So I would agree if this person was using some of the right for sheets out there
wasn't penetrating their body and it didn't help them. So the second quality of a right for sheet
has to penetrate the body, has to be programmable. So if you can't put in the frequencies that you want
to use, it's completely worth us, has to be a user friendly. That's where the GB 4000 falls
in the flat because it's much more difficult to use. It's much more difficult to log around. It's a big
clunky thing. So it's, and then lastly, it has to use a ball. So a lot of right for sheets,
you're holding little things in your hands. So it's really electrical frequency at that light
frequency. And there's benefits to that for different things. You can kill amoebas through that and
things, but you are not going to really kill kids or so, has to have those four qualities.
Back to this Royal Vive, I'm not going to diss any other equipment out there. But an ultrasound
machine has very, has a lot of efficacy for different things. When I did a lot of all musculoskeletal
issues, I had an ultrasound machine in my office. I always loved ultrasound. It was really good for
cysts in tendons. It was really good for other musculoskeletal injuries, muscle injury and such
because you're literally putting in these through these sound waves and breaking up the tissue.
But to me, to use ultrasound with cancer, it's to, I just don't, I just can't wrap my mind around
the physiology. I mean, to me, you could, you have the potential of spreading the cancer.
You don't want to break up the possibility that the body is going to wall off this cancer and stop
it from growing. And then you're going to break it out. I just, to me, it doesn't make any sense why
you've used ultrasound for cancer. I just don't understand that. Can you use P-E-M-F and
R-I-F machine at the same time? Absolutely. Yes. So P-E-M-F is an electrical frequency totally
different way of like, totally different spectrum than R-I-F frequency. So yes, yes, yes, I used to do that
all the time. So we could use both concurrently. There's no harm in that order. A little bit of that
too, discomfort with somebody. Today was concerned about using R-I-F. Of course, they are
depacient of ours yet. They're concerned about using R-I-F, but they had an implantable device.
So when you have an implanted device like a defibrillator or something like that, or one of those
blood sugar monitor things, then you do have to be careful with the P-E-M-F.
R-I-F is not going to hurt any implantable device, any electrical device that you're not going to
have issues with the R-I-F. You may with the P-E-M-F. So you do have to be careful with it. You can
technically still use P-E-M-F on your legs if you have a peripheral neuropathy or something like that,
and you have a defibrillator. You can still do it on your feet, but you do have to be careful
on the intensity that you use, and you certainly wouldn't do it near your heart. If you don't have a
pacemaker or something, you could do the P-E-M-F right over your heart. It's actually really good for you,
but you don't want it to interfere with the implantable device.
Long question. We know that cancer uses glucose to feed itself. Yes, it does.
Very often. And if that is totally cut off, we understand it could switch to glutamine. Let's
make sure we understand this. Cancer can be feeded off of glutamate in the thiety, which are
amino acids right from the get go. And are not feed really off of glucose at all. So that's why we
test for it. But if we block the cancer from using glutamate, or let's just say one-fuex fuel source,
it seems that it can use another pathway, maybe fatty acids. It can use fatty acids, but usually
doesn't because it takes so long to break down fatty acids to become a fuel source. So because of
cancer's high metabolic rate, it typically will not use fatty acids. But it can, so that's why we
test for that. And sometimes we're testing for this particular foods. And let's say pork comes up
and red meat comes up. Well, it's quite possible that it's actually the fatty acids in pork and
red meat. It's not so much the glutamated metiety that is not together possible because we're testing
the food test kit, not the specific backbone nutrient. So that is my possible. So if so, how would we
know to stop this process? That's where you just get another cheek swab and make sure you check
out there that we checked the diet so that we're making sure we're doing that. We are seeing weight
loss that looks to be quite unhealthy. We don't want that. So make sure we check this. I don't know who
asked this question, but whoever it is, maybe you should just schedule a call with me. Or you can
send it to the cheek swab. Now, we're putting on the cheek swab for, make sure you are doughy that
are the cheek swab form. We're sending the cheek swab to our new address. So if you have to
jot this down, make sure you are sending it to our new address. This is our warehouse actually.
This is the fastest way to get it to me. And so that's our new address. So make sure it comes to
this address. It's out of all of our stuff, though, the other back office that you're going to be.
So those that just joined us, we're going to have the new cancer membership site for all our patients
right next week. And you're going to get an email from us saying, hey, you're going to get an email
in a today from our site at that hum spot that will give you access to the new membership site
that you just have to use that email that we're sending to. That's your main email. Use that email
as your user name. Don't try to use a different email because you won't be allowed in. That's how the
membership site works and that's how you keep patients out of it. And that you curate your
and then you'll have access to our new membership site, which will have a bunch of information
that is a data website and has all our zoom cuts. That's how you'll be able to get our zoom calls
this recording will be up in that tomorrow. And also all our all our past. So let's open it up for questions.
We already had some. That's sure how I can how could I diagnose she goes and how could I treat
it at home without the use of data balance. We have a she goes protocol. So make sure you contact
your liaison and we can get the she goes protocol of two. It works, works pretty good. It's not perfect.
But about 70% of the time it really drops the symptoms down to really fast. So that she goes protocol
I've used for decades with people. So next, what is the best method to read THC?
Rub my system. I currently use it for feed and sleep. It's basically the old adage delusion is the
solution to collusion. So in this case, THC will reconsider the pollution and you just have to
do it. So water, supporting your liver, talking to the castoral effects of your liver, just talk
back. So we deliver. Go back and download that seven phases of detox book to help you understand
that. Make sure you're having the following movements. Make sure you're using some binders to
grab onto it. It got so that you get rid of it on the system. You don't reabsorb it. Make sure
it's consummated. So those would be the key things to do to get rid of it. Next question.
If we massage the castoral effect on the liver, can the adguell bladder before using the
sun? Can the heat cause detox of these organs and be beneficial? Think the question is if you
use the castoral effect on your liver and ball bladder, it's such. And then you go and can you
do it in the sauna, is it? Or before you do the sauna, honestly, I think you could do it. You could
do it in the sauna. You could have castoral effect on your liver in the sauna. You could do it
before you do it in the sauna. Absolutely. That's the whole idea. The castoral effect is you're using
heat. So go back and look at the castoral effect in relation to your binder or the website. Again,
you can search for it right there, but the search for castoral effects in the idea of the castoral
will have protocols you're putting heat over the castoral effect. What is the evidence for using any of
the CBD or THC to treat cancer? Well, there's a lot of evidence that's coming out. There's more
and more studies coming out. So I'd suggest you just do a Google Scholar search with that.
Most of it's going to be based upon using it to help with symptoms of
of colleges, use of chemotherapy, but there's a lot of articles that you search for in the use of it.
As far as you see, like Rick Simpson oil to treat cancer, you're not going to find really
I don't know how many articles are going to find out that because I just doubt that there has been
studies that have gotten through by the team. So I've done it for the Friday studies on that.
So that evidence is all animal. I don't believe that a lot of things you'll read about any
thing with cancer is that this cures cancer every time in the course. That's just not a sense of
evidence. So that's why we test for it because it doesn't work with everything.
Okay, what's the difference between the five daytime rape frequencies in my folder? Oh, it's just
for ease of use. So there's five shorter ones in this person's folder. I didn't create five
shorter ones for everybody, but in this case, I did just for ease of use because typically if people
do not have any shorter programs in their folder that I tell them you're going to use it during
the day, just run that night program again. Just for ease of use. If I would cycle through those,
if I created five of them, then they're different, slightly different. So just you just cycle through
them as best you can remember. There's no sequence. So don't worry about that. So boy, I run the right
wave today too. I did the first daytime program. Oh, I can't remember what I did yesterday.
It doesn't make any difference. Just run one of them, try to keep your sequence. That's not
time to question so any other questions. Can you discuss the grounding difference in your
philosophy versus Mike's philosophy? So the grounding pads that are out there, the
grounding pad that came with your right is it's for the eye and throat. So I got to pull up a
grounding sheet and put that up on the screen. So that up here, the picture. So grounding sheet
is something I think this person was talking about. So this is our grounding.
The grounding or earthy sheet that we sell, it looks like that. So it is a clock material
that you would put on the lower half of your bed across this would fit across a king bed.
The lower half I mean from your bucktocks down to your feet and then you'd put the fitted sheet
over the top of it. So you would be able to stay in place and then you plug it to with this
little plug thing. You plug it to that little thing and then you put this either in the ground
of the right machine because that goes back to the ground or you could plug it into the ground
of an outlet. The bottom of a three-prong outlet. So your outlet of the wall has two
prongs on the top. That's positive and negative. In the ground, the bottom, that's the ground.
This little yellow thing is simply a ground tester to see if your own bits are actually
grounded because if it's not grounded, then this thing's not going to do anything.
And the reason why that we include that in there is because often people actually have a three-prong
outlet in their wall, so they think they have grounded outlets, but the electrician who connected
it never actually connected it to the ground, which is really unfortunate. They have had multiple
patients and it's happened to have paid lots of money to have their house really wide.
So if it was properly inspected by an electrical inspector, they would probably contact it.
But that is how you use a groundy sheet. I know there's philosophies out there and I think it's
the right place that you should use. Everybody should use a groundy sheet and you should use it on
your whole bed. But understand, your right frequencies are going to be attractive to the ground,
to this groundy sheet. So if you are using a groundy sheet and you have it on your whole bed,
and you have your ball on your tummy, and you're laying on your back, well, there's no harm, no foul,
because those frequencies are going right to you to the ground. But even at that, think about it.
We want these frequencies to go throughout your whole body, not just mainly through your chest to
the ground. We want them to go up to your head. We want them to go down your feet.
So if you have a ground that's on the full side of the bed, and you roll over to the side and the
ball falls right next to your sheet, but maybe it's even still touching your body, you're going to lose
a lot of those frequencies right to the groundy sheet, back through that wire, back to the electrical
system, into the groundy rod, into the ground. So if you use a groundy sheet, this my philosophy,
you only use it on the lower half of your bed. Using it on the lower half of the bed,
usually you're going to be just fine, unless you are putting your ball way down low on your body,
and it's way down by your feet, or something like that. But hopefully everybody's listening to my
instruction and you're kind of struggling with that ball up at your chest, all the telling you
that it might fall down by your side, but it's not falling down by your leg. So if you use a groundy
sheet, I think you should use the groundy sheet only on the lower half of your body. You're still
getting the benefits of the groundy, but you're not losing the frequencies. So the benefits of the
groundy are immense. I would tell people to read the book or thing that can help you understand
that we pick up, we are basically antennas, that we pick up different charges, you're picking up a
positive charge all the time, and I don't mean positive by good, it's a positive charge. And then
you have to disperse that charge. And the best way you do it is you go walk around in the grass
with your bare feet, and you're going to disperse that charge, and you'll pick up electrodes from the
earth. That's the benefit of pets. That's the benefit of horseback riding, horse, or dog is running around,
grouting itself on the earth, all day long if you let it outside, horses standing on the ground,
grouting itself, it's a great conductor of electricity. That's why horse therapy is so good for
autistic kids, for abused people, for alcohol, like addiction people, it could just settle your
braid down. It's all has to do with groundy. So it's horse horses are nice too. So they're just like
chicken, like dogs. But that's what earth thing or using a groundy cheat can do for you. You could
actually use these groundy cheats on your chair, let's say your desk chair that you sit at all day.
I used to have one plugged in by chair before we moved, and you have it plugged into the wall, so
you're basically growing yourself on time. So it's very beneficial. Oh, I'm going to go with these
questions. I wrapped the right lamp with a dark fabric and put it under the top sheet next to the
bed. I am still getting the results. Yep, you are. So you could put your right, your right
machine won't penetrate putting a tube sock on it or something like that to keep you from being
blinded by the light at night. It won't penetrate your body. It's not going to be pretty good.
You're too right. This should penetrate that just fine. What's the difference between natural sweeters?
Are some more harmful than others? I get conflicted into info. How does sugar in fruit affect cancer?
How does monk fruit desilatol stevia affect cancer? Yeah, it is very confusing. So when we test
four things, we test that sugar is even a driver in your cancer. If it is, then we tell you that
well, if sugar isn't the driver in your cancer,
if I smoke fruit, just know that these won't be either. If sugar is a driver of your cancer,
can you use monk fruit? Well, it still is sugar. So you still have to be careful with how much you
use of that. Is silatol a driver of your cancer? If sugar is, no. Silatol is not sugar, so it's
completely different. That's a type of sugar alcohol. And is stevia a driver of your cancer? No,
stevia is not a driver of your cancer. You'd never see that to do a driver of your cancer.
So it's hard to know, okay, well, how do I know what should we do it? No, no, but what?
Because there's so much information out there. The bottom line is, it's just trying to use common
sense in that you're not doing simply one thing all the time. So you're doing a mixture of different
things could be very beneficial. It's like it's like the old edits that they used to say for years
is that we were really created to eat in season. It doesn't make any sense to me that we could eat
apples every single day of our life. That's that the way God made it. Think of how God made
things to come in season. Yes, we're supposed to be able to pick apples and put them in cold storage
so that we could maybe stretch out that season to maybe six months instead of only two months.
That we could get stuff from another part of the world that is now that's in season for those people
and we can keep eating them. Think about that. Maybe that's not really not good for us. Maybe we
should have this rotational diet or we're not eating the same thing all the time. So even with things
like that, I think that's why you get conflicting data of things like this. This is monk fruit is
good for you. You should eat monk fruit as your sugar substitute, but then you get data that says
little monk fruit isn't good for you. Well, I think it's because it's not good for you all the time.
So having mixing things up can be very beneficial. I think there's just a lot of wisdom
get that so that you're doing more of a rotational diet. You don't have to follow the eating in season
where all normally apples would be in season here. So I'm not going to eat them until they come into
a season. It's just rotating. You're not eating them all the time. I mean, some people get it to
have it where they're eating but it is every single day. Maybe that says it's a good idea. I don't know
I'm just saying, just think about it. What happens if you do not use the ground bean sheet
when the rice machine is running? Use the ground bean sheet whether I'm using the ground bean sheet at
all. So understand, on my bed, I don't have a ground bean sheet. So and that's why we don't push
selling the ground bean sheet. So we have them. You can buy them from us.
But we don't ever push them. You never hear us talking about error. You need a ground bean sheet
because I don't think everybody should get a ground bean sheet because I think there could be this
use of it and you could lose a lot of the frequencies that rather have you get the frequencies
while you're sleeping and getting grounded. You could grow yourself during the day.
Does the more color and sediments indicate effectiveness of the food footbat?
The answer is you maybe. So I've never been a big fan of saying, oh wow, look at the drought in
the water. It must be coming out of my liver or anything like that. I know there's charts
that you can Google them. I just don't think they're accurate. I just don't believe
that fully. And you're not doing the footbat necessarily to pull all this gum dotty. You're doing
the footbat to run different frequencies that can be beneficial. Yes, it may pull some gum dotty
you too. So don't be hung up on that. Do metal coils in your mattress interfere with the right
for sheet? No, they don't interfere with the right for sheet at all. I can't interfere with
some things I suppose. I mean, some people that are highly sensitive to electromagnetic radiation
if they feel maybe that could be positive. I don't know. I think different people have different
sensitivities that they do need to address different things like that. Some of the new mattresses
like those purple mattresses and those memory foam mattresses. I think there's maybe
you've got to look at the dangers of how those are made. I know there's one company that's not
the purple company that makes it all natural, not a toxic. I don't know what they use it. I don't
know, it's not that she's really like that. But you got to look at the toxic things in the mattresses
and stuff too. I think that's even more of a danger. The different fire retardants that
government has forced companies to use in things like that are highly toxic. Cancer-causing
things in themselves. And you have to be careful of those as well. Should I take the Mughal's solution
2% iodine to help with my cancer. If you haven't got your binder back,
you'll see if that tested or not. You can't really hurt yourself with Mughal's except I take
you can by taking too much of it. Personally, I'm not a fan of Mughal's solution. I'm more of a
fan of the kelp-based iodides. If you're going to use iodine, I'm more of a fan of kelp-based iodine
because it's more of a whole food-based iodine. It's a better iodine solution than
potassium iodine. But typically, taking iodine, there's really got a lot of negatives. So, if you
have that, then you take the low doses of it, you know, the standard dose of it that's listed on the
bottle. What type of program is that use a different bulb? What type of cold is it use a different
bulb and a grounding mat? Are there types of programs that use a different bulb and a grounding mat?
So, if you look at the program in the right, it'll show pictures of a person using a different bulb
and using a grounding mat. Maybe you'll even say that's what you should do. There's some applications
that that make sense. Okay? So, I'm just going to do the right on my tooth. Maybe I want to put a
grounding mat on my upper back so the frequencies are going more directly right to the right to the
grounding mat. So, you can think of it that way. The grounding mat is going to attract the frequencies.
So, the draw line between the bulb and the grounding mat, that's going to be the general direction of
the frequencies. Not all of them, but the general direction. So, strategic use of a grounding mat
and you're beneficial, I guess. So, if you think of it that way, you can understand that.
Should you use a different bulb? Well, the hammer bulb is one of the strongest bulbs. There's the
double bubble with the screen back. That's a little bit stronger. Certainly, you can't use that at night.
But it is stronger, especially if you touch it to your skin. So, there's, I mean, we have multiple
bulbs. They're quite a care, but honestly, most of them are just using the hammer bulb.
We at home, I only have the hammer bulb. So, you don't need to understand,
love, like it's right, but it isn't a business assembly thing. So, you don't need to get
the numbers over there. Can you use those programs, even the
bulb that you have, or don't probably bet? Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So, for those of you that are new to this call, you're also new to the right. So, when you start
using your right, you want to make it, it's, again, I told everybody it's not a fantasy of all disease,
but it should be your first go-to thing for everything. So, all my child's got an earring,
run the ear infection programs. Oh, my daughter's got a little sore throat, run the strap programs
on her. Some of them are short, some of them are maybe an hour or two long. As long as they'll
sit there, run the program. Use that for your first go-to. Think of it as your medicine cabinet
that you should use as your first go-to on everything. So, that fix the problem, but certainly it's
going to help, especially if you had other things like nutrition at least, too, as well.
You don't be afraid to use them, they're right. You cannot overuse it, you'll never go out
your bulb. You're not going to have a problem with them until you're right. Two raves at home,
what is now probably go-to three years old, and one is try to be an adult, a year's old. So,
can you use the right on anybody? Yes, you can use it on a baby, you can use it on a pregnant woman,
yes, you can use it on everybody. Two rags don't make a line. I don't really know this guy,
but he's a dad, you know, he can tell. It's quality. Quality there. All right, with that, I think we'll
bit of do. Thank you guys for being on tonight. Again, you could email your questions in,
and soon as we have the membership page, you could do it right now. All right,
we prayed for everybody. I asked it to you guys to pray for us, pray for protection, pray for
just health and safety. We're going to be praying for you. Oh, let's forget. Please, please, please,
if you haven't done this, can you guys please email us a picture, can be you, can be your family,
but it's kind of you in there. So, okay, so that's just a picture you don't. So, set us a picture,
because we're putting up a very new, big, giant magnetic prayer board in our office, and I will
have to get everybody's picture up there for our prayer board. So, please email it to info at
Cuttersplidic. I will get it in person. We'll get it up for the prayer board.
Thank you, fans. Love you all. Bye bye.